No,
I don't.
I don't think that the growth of
nonprofits and specifically
environmental nonprofits has diluted
surfrider foundation at all in that back
to I love having more help anywhere we
can get it.
The more the merrier.
It's great.
I think what is changing,
as I mentioned a while ago was a w was
everything that happened in the 90s all
the technology we can now in about 14
hours send 10,000 emails to government
Schwartzenegger on an issue.
We can send 20,000 emails to people in
Chile.
I mean we can tap people,
we can talk face to face all over the
world using skype.
We do.
Um,
those things are radically shifting the
toolset,
the capabilities and the power that is
at the edge of the network of our
culture.
So all of a sudden you don't have to be
Rupert Murdoch Buying The Wall Street
Journal to have your hand on the
joystick.
You can be 10,000 people in Argentina.
You can do this a lot of different ways
as long as you understand and implement
technology.
One of my favorite things that just came
out was a $99 video player that records
on flash the size of a cell phone.
They gave them away as freebies at this
conference that I'm at right now.
Very,
very powerful tool.
No,
I think something has shifted in the
last 12 months,
which is radically different than it was
before.
It used to be that business was bad,
government was slow,
Ngo Dash virus.
We're good.
There are where all the smart people
we're,
et cetera in anything with a corporate
brand was essentially bad.
And what has happened in the last 12
months is that governments are still
slow.
I think they'll always be slow.
Business has flipped from one of their
emotions to the other emotion and they
only have two emotions.
And the one emotion that they were in
was fear.
They didn't understand the environment,
they didn't understand the cost of all
these things,
and they do now.
So you have Jim Rogers,
CEO of Duke Energy,
amazing guy making amazing statements.
Walmart is making amazing strides to
dupont making amazing strides.
So now they flipped over to their other
convenient emotion,
which is greed.
Business has the capital,
they have the reach,
they have the infrastructure,
they have the,
uh,
distribution channel to consumers.
Business will drive the green movement.
It's also what Thomas Friedman saying,
and a new kind of green is the new red,
white and blue people are saying green
was the new gold,
et cetera.
And it's not as simple as that.
Businesses are cashing in.
That's not the message at all.
Businesses will cash in regardless.
The point is that the globe is in a
crisis mode.
It's red lining.
And,
and businesses cannot sustain their
model unless adapt.
And they are much quicker to adapt than
a government,
which we're seeing all over the world.